greetings my benefactor wishes to speak
to you about a matter that could affect
the fate of our world if my benefactor
wish to discuss details in the open why
Santa messenger the matter is for your
ears only my benefactor awaits nearby do
not tarry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
Wow there are you all right
the names Liris I hope you've still got
some fight left in you
you guys you made it
[Music]
must have been the runt of the litter
[Music]
keep your weapon ready and stay sharp
this place is full of surprises
keep moving there are more Daedra on the
way let's keep moving
keep moving
more guards are on the way
let's get out of here my friend profit
breeding lizard like you I am a prisoner
in this place
you must rescue me and I in turn must
rescue you all the moment come here we
need to talk the Prophet he's a prisoner
here too
it was very dangerous for him to speak
to you even for a moment break him out
of course believe me I can use all the
help I can get these tunnels will
eventually take us to the towers of eyes
that's where we'll find the Sentinels
magical constructs created by Molag Bal
to guide his vision in Coldharbour the
Sentinels are I have no idea
brute force will find a way I'm sure you
do we should keep moving
[Music]
well played friend mark Hayes beard you
are good in a fight a daughter brutality
knows of your speed three
the god of schemes can see every part of
the harbor we need to distract him
what was your name again target practice
yeah
you will never escape my realm the doors
warded we'll never get in this way
damnit destroying the Sentinel must have
triggered these wards we'll need a bot
Cadwell is the oldest of the soul
shriven after years of torment soul
shriven usually goes Cadwell sees things
as he wishes them to be to him cold
Harbor is a wondrous place
one finder in the middle of the night
two dead Kings got up to fight back to
back thee hello what's this out for us
sir cat well the yes indeed a pleasure
oh dear oh dear
well that is inconvenient isn't it
anyone I'm rather cautiously I expect
follow the missive luck dude
Cadwell seems to think this undercroft
is a delightful place
is a deathtrap better be careful
[Music]
as soon you get that door open the
sooner we can get out of here
[Music]
come get some more you scheming hawkers
the prophets cage should be just ahead
quickly now we haven't much time
all right the good news is we made it
here in one piece and the profit looks
unharmed now the bad news it's going to
be up to you to keep him safe and get
him back to Tamriel
there's a trick to opening myself the
only way for a prisoner to leave is for
another living once it's done get moving
the prophet
freedom I remember wish that were
possible thank the Divine's you are safe
there is that at least I wish that were
possible but I promise you that is the
name I have given you you are but it
that is what I've come to be called the
anchors are up the stairs quickly we
must get to the anchor mooring
a mortal thinks it can define me
futile soon your world will be in my
chains
I will protect you
a moment message the dark Angus portal
is high above us I will prepare a spell
to lift us to it a shard of ethereal
Magica that carries the essence of known
summoning them to Lawton
shard of Aetherius fall upon us now and
anoint us with your blessing yeah
quickly collect the sky shot great
akatosh dragon god of time I require
your strength let the way be opened that
these wandering souls return home that
the will of Molag Bal be denied
you
as I feared
we arrived in different locations I am
in a city near the sea in a land of its
days weeks
I cannot tell the boys I'm afraid you
will have to decide that for yourself
I cannot foresee that not yet beware a
vestige already